représentant de la Cour des comptes venu
nous présenter le rapport public
thématique publié le 3 avril dernier et
instituter la stratégie nationale de
recherche en intelligence
artificielle il s'agit plus précisément
monsieur le Président de la section
enseignement supérieur et recherche
heureux de vous ré-accueillir puisque
vous êtes venu il y a quelques semaines
nous présenter également les résultats
de vos travaux sur
l'université et les territoires
de vous accueillir ainsi que Messieurs
Gwenaëlle Roudaut Monsieur François
monsieur Roudaut n'est pas là je crois
non pardon Monsieur François Saint-Paul
monsieur Mathieu mosselonca Lefebvre et
mesdames Flora Seguin ainsi que Madame
Marie Roger Vasselin
mesdames et messieurs nous vous
remercions d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation
vous doutez que le sujet de
l'intelligence artificielle qui prend
une place croissante dans le débat
public intéresse évidemment notre
commission pour ces liens étroit avec le
secteur de l'enseignement supérieur et
plus spécifiquement de la recherche mais
aussi pour ces répercussions dans
d'autres champs relevant de nos domaines
de compétences comme ceux de l'éducation
et de la culture une stratégie nationale
pour l'intelligence artificielle a été
lancée en mars 2018
avec pour objectif de positionner la
France
comme l'un des acteurs majeurs en
intelligence artificielle sur
l'échiquier mondial initialement doté de
1,5 milliards d'euros de financement
public pour la période de 2018-2022
cette stratégie s'est déployée autour de
5 volets la recherche l'enseignement
supérieur la transformation publique la
diffusion dans l'économie et enfin la
défense et la sécurité en novembre
2021 une nouvelle phase de la SNIA
d'accélération a été annoncée pour la
période
2021-2025 avec pour objectif de
renforcer la compétitivité
l'attractivité de la France dans ce
domaine votre rapport dresse le constat
général d'une politique publique en
faveur de l'intelligence artificielle
qui je cite à bel et bien favorisé une
première structuration d'un écosystème
d'enseignement supérieur et de recherche
mais dont l'efficacité n'est pas avérée
en effet si la France
ne décroche pas à l'échelle mondiale
elle conserve difficilement sa place au
dixième rang en nombre de publications
on y a et la maintient en deuxième rang
au niveau européen face à ce diagnostic
vous recommandé de mieux structurer et
pérenniser l'écosystème de recherche
d'excellence qui s'est développé depuis
2018 vous insistez aussi sur les besoins
en enseignant et en enseignant
chercheurs formés à l'usage de l'IA
avant de vous céder la parole pour une
présentation plus détaillée de vos
rapports de vos constats et de vos
propositions je me permets de vous
rappeler que cette audition fait l'objet
d'une captation vidéo retransmise en
direct sur le site internet du Sénat et
puis après votre intervention limitée
sénatrice et sénateurs bien sûr
interviendront et poseront toutes les
questions qui le souhaitent j'excuse
lors d'Arco de son absence rapporteur
sur les crédits recherchent mais qui m'a
néanmoins laissé quelques questions que
je poserai en son nom après votre
intervention c'est le Président je vous
laisse la parole merci beaucoup monsieur
le Président nous sommes vraiment ravis
d'être à nouveau en effet parmi vous
après notre présentation de du rapport
que vous citiez il y a quelques il y a
quelques semaines avec une équipe que je
n'ai pas représentée mais qui est une
équipe de la troisième chambre de la
Cour des comptes qui est posée par le
président Nasser MEDA et et la présence
nombreuse de rapporteurs et encore toute
l'équipe n'est pas au complet montre
l'investissement que vous avons
nous-mêmes consenti l'année dernière sur
ce travail donc c'est une enquête
importante pour nous nous sommes ravis
donc de pouvoir vous la présenter elle a
été publiée comme vous le savez en avril
alors c'est une évaluation de politique
publique c'est important pour nous vous
trouverez peut-être des caractéristiques
différentes du rapport que j'évoquais
que le président évoqué université
territoire puisque nous avons une
méthodologie très particulière vous vous
souvenez que la Cour des Comptes est
compétente en matière d'évaluation
depuis 2008 depuis l'Artic 47 2 de la
Constitution lui a donné cette
compétence et que nous avons de par la
loi donc le code gestion financière une
compétence pour réaliser ces évaluations
nous en avons réalisé une trentaine
depuis elles sont toutes publiques de
depuis que la loi nous donne cette
compétence soit d'initiative comme c'est
le cas aujourd'hui soit à la demande
théoriquement du gouvernement qui n'a
jamais exercé ce droit ou du Parlement
et je nous disions évoquions avec le
président que l'Assemblée nationale a
trouvé le bouton le guichet donc il nous
arrive fréquemment de de répondre à des
commandes de l'assemblation des
commandes d'évaluation je dis bien nous
souhaitons qu'un jour le Sénat veuille
bien à nous confier une chambre de la
Cour une demande d'évaluation voilà ça
aurait pu être celle-là ça pourrait être
une autre en fonction de vos centres
d'intérêt mais je pense que il en sera
parlé en autre lieu donc c'est une
évaluation ça veut dire que du point de
vue de la méthodologie je ne serai pas
trop trop lourd à la fois nous répondons
à des questions évaluatives donc vous
allez voir quelques questions
évaluatives et en fait une relation
c'est simplement tenter de répondre de
manière objective
magnifique ça représente pour la société
et pour introduire ce que mes collègues
vont vous présenter peut-être une
vingtaine de minutes
la question se pose de savoir comment on
part d'un point d'excellence qui est
notre excellence en mathématiques la
France l'école mathématique française
vous savez tous c'est une des premières
au monde et nous avons encore et ces
mesurables des résultats tout à fait
exceptionnels par rapport à ce qu'il a
la taille de notre pays et comment
convertir comment ne pas perdre dans la
réalisation la traduction puisque
l'intelligence artificielle se nourrit
naturellement de ces de ses disciplines
c'est un peu comme ça qu'on a vu les
choses et donc est-ce qu'on capte bien
ce cet acquis cette acquis historique on
va pas parler de Bourbaki ici pour pour
mettre en place et garder notre rang
en doute l'importance voilà un petit peu
le fil directeur et je si vous voulez
bien monsieur le Président je propose
que les membres de l'équipe à tour de
rôle donc fera ce gain qui a qui a
coordonné travaux France Saint-Paul qui
est un diplôme très émérite qui a fait
une carrière tout à fait on est très
heureux d'avoir la Cour des comptes qui
a cette intéressé aux aspects
comparatifs aux stratégies des autres
bien entendu Mathieu qui était Mathieu
qui était un scientifique qui travaille
avec à la cour comme conseiller
référendaire voilà une équipe et puis
Marie qui nous a rejoint sorti de c'est
encore Léna voilà c'est les dernières
promotions il y a pas de temps voilà
donc si vous voulez bien je peux
c'est
Marie qui commence c'est moi qui vais
commencer
merci monsieur le Président vous pouvez
passer aussi à la slide suivante vous
l'avez rappelé la stratégie sur laquelle
on s'est penché l'année dernière c'est
une stratégie en intelligence
artificielle qui est en cours de
déploiement qui a été lancé en 2018
et qui a qui connaît maintenant le
nouveau nouvelle phase depuis l'année
dernière dans lequel une stratégie
d'accélération une stratégie
d'accélération qui cible toujours la
recherche
sur sur cette stratégie c'est une
stratégie donc qui
s'est mise en oeuvre dans un contexte où
l'écosystème des acteurs en intelligence
artificielle c'est un écosystème fourni
il y a de nombreux acteurs que ce soit
en termes de pilotage dans la recherche
dans la formation et donc il y avait en
effet un enjeu pour la première phase de
la stratégie en intelligence
artificielle de structurer l'écosystème
en intelligence art ificielle
elle affiché pour cela un double
objectif installer durablement la France
dans le top 5 des pays experts en
intelligence artificielle à l'échelle
mondiale et faire de la France le leader
européen de la recherche en intelligence
artificielle donc deux objectifs
ambitieux qu'on a cherché à évaluer
effectivement en s'appuyant sur sur une
méthodologie que je vais maintenant
décrire avec d'abord la volonté pour la
cour de faire une évaluation donc
multiniveaux c'est-à-dire d'abord en
regardant les effets de la stratégie sur
ces impacts et quel a été l'effet d'une
de la formalisation d'une stratégie sur
la politique publique en intelligence
artificielle quand on regarde ensuite au
niveau des différentes actions de la
stratégie quels ont été aussi l'impact
de chacune des actions que que la
stratégie prévoyait et ensuite est-ce
qu'en termes d'externalité il y a eu des
éléments positifs donc sur la sur la
politique publique en intelligence
artificielle plus largement
donc pour se faire on a répondu à 4 on a
cherché en tout cas à répondre à quatre
questions évaluatives qu'on rappelle ici
donc d'abord une première question qui
est directement liée aux objectifs que
se fixait la stratégie nationale en
intelligence artificielle et son volet
recherche donc la stratégie nationale de
recherche en intelligence artificielle à
tel permis de renforcer la position de
la France au niveau mondial et européen
première question ensuite est-ce que
cette stratégie elle a permis une fine
et la structuration de l'écosystème
français en intelligence artificielle
dont on a vu qu'il y avait de nombreux
acteurs
ensuite la stratégie est-ce que en
s'appuyant sur la mise en place de pôle
d'excellence est-ce que c'est efficace
et efficient et enfin
et notamment par rapport aujourd'hui à
la à la seconde phase qui est lancée
est-ce que elle a permis d'améliorer la
prise en compte des enjeux éthiques en
intelligence artificielle et notamment
en ce qui concerne ce qu'on appelle
l'intelligence ence artificielle frugale
et l'intelligence artificielle de
confiance
donc pour répondre à ces questions on
s'est appuyé sur une sur une
méthodologie avec
différentes méthodes donc un
parangonnage effectivement qu'on a mené
en étudiant les stratégies de différents
pays on regardant aussi les différents
classements internationaux et on sait
aussi appuyer sur des méthodes à la fois
quantitatives et qualitative donc à la
fois pour le volet quantitatif de la
scientométrie de l'économétrie et aussi
des analyses de réseau
pour mettre en place cette méthodologie
et notamment sur son volet quantitatif
on s'est appuyé sur un certain nombre de
données à la fois Macron Mezzo et micro
qu'on a récolté auprès d'un certain
nombre d'acteurs que vous pouvez voir à
l'écran donc le CDE l'Agence nationale
de recherche par exemple
mais mais et donc ça vous montre aussi
que les à la fois l'écosystème il repose
sur de nombreux acteurs mais les données
aussi qu'on peut avoir pour mesurer
l'efficacité de la stratégie du coup
elles sont aussi
présentes donc dans différentes
administrations auprès de différents
acteurs il a fallu faire un travail de
collecte important de ces données
donc je passe d'abord du coup au premier
constat du coup de notre rapport qui est
que la priorité de la stratégie donnée à
la recherche n'a pas encore produit les
effets attendus et avec d'abord quand
même le fait qu'on peut signaler et
souligner que la France est l'un des
premiers pays à
s'être dotée donc d'une stratégie en
intelligence artificielle on le rappelle
dans le rapport un des premiers pays
avec avec la Finlande des 2018 et avec
des financements donc qui pour la
période
2018-2022 portait effectivement
principalement sur la recherche d'où
notre évaluation puisque sur les 1,5
milliards qui étaient prévus donc pas
pour la première phase de la stratégie
il y avait en prévisionnel 445 millions
d'euros qui étaient prévus sur le volet
recherche avec différents axes
structurants qui avaient été ensuite
déterminés pour décliner ce volet
recherche
ce qui est intéressant de voir c'est que
la stratégie nationale de recherche en
intelligence artificielle effectivement
elle a prévu des financements importants
pour la pour la recherche sur la période
2018-2022 et en fait ce qu'on voit c'est
que de manière concomitante on a cette
priorité de l'intelligence artificielle
qui diffuse au-delà même du strict
déploiement de la stratégie donc pour
étayer ce constat on a regardé notamment
les les projets déposés et retenus au
sein de l'Agence nationale de recherche
depuis 2014 et est-ce qu'on voit c'est
que les la part des dossiers qui ont été
déposés dans l'appel à projet générique
elle est passée de 10% en 2014 après de
17% en 2019 et celle des projets retenus
à moins de 10% en 2014 à plus de 16% en
2019 donc on voit que il y a eu une
impulsion en tout cas à cette période
plus globale sur l'intelligence
artificielle et on peut faire ce même
constat en regardant les les projets
dont financés par le programme Horizon
20 20 puisque on voit que alors que le
nombre total de projets est presque
stable sur la période précédente et bien
c'est passé de la part de projets en
intelligence artificielle elle est
passée de un peu plus de 7% en 2014 à
21% en 2020 et cette croissance elle est
aussi visible pour pour les projets
retenus
néanmoins si on voit que cette priorité
en intelligence artificielle a diffusée
effectivement au de la même de la
stricte du strict déploiement de la
stratégie
une des premières difficultés à laquelle
on a été confronté c'est que
l'efficience de la stratégie elle est
difficile à appréhender parce que le
suivi des financements associés et est
insuffisant
la stratégie a été financée à partir
d'un dispositif budgétaire qui reposait
sur des outils financiers existants donc
il y a une raison à cela c'était aussi
pour que la voilà le la stratégie puisse
être déployée rapidement mais du coup ça
ça rend l'architecture budgétaire
complexe de la stratégie et ça rend
difficile le suivi des financements
associés et par ailleurs on observe que
la majorité des financements de la
stratégie ça a été distribué via des
appels à projets et donc avec du coup
des financements de courte durée
donc on rappelle les les ce qu'on peut
voir c'est les autorisations
d'engagement donc été initialement
prévus pour pour la stratégie et ensuite
on peut essayer de mettre en évidence ce
qui infinie a été engagé mais quand même
avec la difficulté que dans ces crédits
là tout ce n'était pas fléchés
directement sur la stratégie en
intelligence artificielle et il est
difficile de voir vraiment l'exécution
des financements associés et d'où une
première recommandation de notre rapport
qui était de traduire la politique
publique sur l'intelligence artificielle
dans un document budgétaire de synthèse
qui permettra de mieux suivre les
financements associés donc du coup de
mesurer les effets de l'engagement
financier sur sur cette priorité
bonjour monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs sénateurs
donc je vais vous présenter la suite
donc notamment sur le l'enjeu de la
première question évaluatif qui vous a
été présentée sur le positionnement
scientifique de la France donc la
question était de savoir si la stratégie
nationale de recherche a permis
d'installer la France dans le top 5 des
experts en Y a à l'échelle mondiale et
renforcer sa position au niveau européen
la première chose que la course a
observé dans son rapport c'est que la
recherche joue un rôle très structurant
dans le positionnement des différents
pays en analysant un très grand nombre
d'indicateurs c'est un point qu'on
développe dans le rapport et donc le
choix qui a été fait de centrer à la
stratégie sur la recherche dans le
premier volet tu as un choix opportun ce
qu'on observe c'est que en 2021 comme
l'a rappelé le président en introduction
la France et au dixième rang mondial et
au deuxième rang européen et quand on
regarde l'évolution entre 2014 et 2021
on voit que le rang de la France
apparaît en diminution quel que soit
l'indicateur analysé donc là on vous
présente les publications le nombre de
publications et le nombre de citations
d'articles en intelligence artificielle
il faut quand même préciser que les
effets concrets de la stratégie vont
être difficiles à apprécier à court
terme parce qu'il y a un décalage
parfois très long entre les financements
qui sont octroyés et la production
scientifique donc ce sera très
intéressant je pense à l'avenir de
d'actualiser ses résultats pour voir la
l'évolution en série longue par ailleurs
l'absence de stratégie aurait pu
conduire à un décrochage de la France on
a notamment réalisé dans le rapport
c'est un point un peu technique on a
réalisé des analyses économétriques qui
montrent qu'il y a un intérêt pour les
pays à faire une stratégie
d'intelligence artificielle donc c'était
encore une fois un choix opportun il y
en aurait pu décrocher bien davantage en
l'absence de stratégie si on passe à la
statique suivante on voit en termes de
cette fois-ci de valorisation de la
recherche en prenant par exemple les
brevets donc une réelle dynamique en
augmentation depuis 2018 donc là vous
avez deux courbes une courbe qui montre
l'évolution du nombre de brevets pour
l'ensemble du monde et une courbe qui
montre pour la France donc là on est en
base 100 ce qui nous permet te montrer
que en 2014 et on parle de la même base
et on voit que le la dynamique de
croissance des brevets pour la France
est plus élevé que pour le reste du
monde donc on a l'impression qu'il y a
des signaux positifs en termes de
valorisation il y a aussi des signaux
positifs sur les startups c'est évoqué
dans le rapport il y a un peu encore un
peu difficile de voir les effets sur
l'économie parce que brevet start-up
sont des signaux positifs mais c'est
encore
l'implication concrète sur l'économie
c'est encore un autre aspect et c'est
pas un point qui a été au cœur du
rapport c'est un point qui serait aussi
intéressant à regarder dans l'avenir si
on part sur le la suite
donc je vais vous présenter rapidement
la deuxième partie du rapport donc sur
l'écosystème à mieux structuré
pérenniser
la stratégie nationale de recherche en
intelligence artificielle prévoit la
constitution de pôles d'excellence qui a
donné lieu à la labilisation d'instituts
interdisciplinaire en intelligence
artificielle les instituts du troisia
ainsi que des chers individuels qui
permettent à une répartition sur le
territoire national il y a aussi des
centres d'excellence qui ont été
identifiés en parallèle donc au total il
y a quatre instituts troisia qui sont
présentés sur la carte vous avez
l'Institut prairie en Île-de-France vous
avez anniti à Toulouse le troisième Côte
d'Azur à Nice et le troisième à Grenoble
vous avez aussi trois centres
d'excellence qui sont montés en
parallèle qui sont basés en
Île-de-France donc Sky dataia et hyperis
sachant que un de ces centres existait
déjà préalablement dataïa parce qu'il a
été labellisé dans le cadre d'un
précédent appel à la projet qui
s'appelle institut convergence donc vous
avez 7 7 pôles d'excellence et dont vous
pouvez voir sur le graphique en à gauche
qui ont une bonne productivité
scientifique parce que ils ont le nombre
de publications a augmenté pour
l'ensemble de ces sites ces sites
d'excellence sur la période d'examinée
est-ce qu'on voit toutefois c'est que la
performance relative des instituts 3ia
par rapport au aux autres centres et
comparable donc il y a pas de d'effets
différenciant des objets spécifiques de
la stratégie on a aussi observé donc là
sur un plan plus financier que ces
centres donc une absence de visibilité
sur leur financement à long terme et sur
la base de l'ensemble de ces éléments la
cour à recommander préciser les missions
respectives des centres d'excellence
troisia et e3ia et de clarifier en
conséquence les financements pluraluels
qui leur sont à l'eau
la stratégie
aussi comporter d'un investissement
capital humain pour notamment la
formation des futurs talents de
l'intelligence artificielle donc ça
c'est quelque chose qu'on peut suivre
notamment par l'évolution des tests
soutenus on peut les suivre en série
très longue comme ici depuis les années
89 où on voit une très forte
augmentation des tests qui ont été
soutenus en
IA donc notamment tout particulièrement
dans des domaines comme le
l'apprentissage profond ce qu'on appelle
le Deep learning avec un accroissement
de 694
%, aussi un accroissement très fort dans
le domaine du machine learning qui est
un domaine plus large qui recouvre le
diplôme learning
voilà donc ça c'est une dynamique très
forte beaucoup de thèses notamment en
informatique et là si on regarde ce qui
se passe donc sur la diapositive
suivante sur la période plus récente
alors on n'avait pas accès aux données
accords des tests qui mettent un certain
temps à être pour l'ensemble des tests
qui mettent du temps à être monté mais
on a pu regarder ce qui se passe pour
les conventions industrielles de
formation par la recherche donc les
thèses
qui sont en partenariat entre
l'entreprise et le monde académique et
on voit que sur la période 2014-2021 le
nombre de tacifs en lien avec l'IA a
plus que doubler notamment en 2019 sous
l'effet de la stratégie il y a eu 50
passifs qui ont été financés
spécifiquement pour lias qui a conduit
un pic et depuis c'est resté un niveau
un niveau élevé autour de 250 235 tests
par an donc ça on a l'impression qu'il y
a eu un effet
à ce niveau là
il y a eu aussi des classes stratégies
qu'on porte différents outils un autre
outil qu'elle comporte notamment c'est
la mise en oeuvre d'infrastructures de
calculs souveraines avec la mise en
place du supercalculateur Janzé en 2019
qui a connu une appropriation rapide par
la commune de thé scientifique
puisqu’après seulement 18 mois de mise
en service le calculateur était déjà
saturé avec 70% de projets en lien avec
lia et une répartition territoriale qui
suit la distribution des pôles
d'excellence on a l'impression qu'il y a
voilà aussi un succès avec une mesure
pertinente qui a répondu à des besoins
donc comme ça a été évoqué en première
partie il y a un autre enjeu important
de la stratégie qui était la
structuration d'un écosystème riche et
diversifiée
par contre voilà que nos homologues
allemands s'en sortent un peu mieux sur
le plan des relations avec le monde
économique
bonjour monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs donc une
gouvernance qui a été affaibli avec le
temps et fragmenté à laquelle il faut
mieux associer les parties prenantes
voilà la conclusion à laquelle nous nous
avons abouti dans la mesure où nous
avons constaté le fait que si des
mesures avaient été prises au moment de
l'engagement de la SNIA la société la
stratégie nationale en intelligence
artificielle ça continue c'est dans le
temps n'avait pas été garantie puisque
le poste notamment de coordinateur de
national de cette stratégie avait été
laissé vacant pendant près de huit mois
pendant la période sous revue pendant
laquelle nous avons mené cette
évaluation et que évidemment la Cour a
recommandé des tas de lumière de manière
partagée des objectifs et des
indicateurs prioritaires pour garantir
cette continuité d'une stratégie
nationale relativement jeune en lien
avec la stratégie européenne bien
évidemment et de créer de pourvoir le
poste qui avait été donc les ses
vacances alors que cette stratégie est
jeune et que la nécessité de lui
garantir une pérennité dans le temps est
absolument nécessaire et de lui créer de
un comité scientifique et de pilotage
auprès d'Inria qui évidemment le pilote
l'organisme national recherche de
recherche pilote en la matière en la
matière qu'au présidé par France
université pour suivre de manière
concertée la mise en oeuvre de cette
stratégie est définie évidemment les
futurs orientations stratégiques
définies avec le ministère de
l'Enseignement et de la Recherche et
évidemment d'Inria
sur l'accélération de la stratégie avec
une approche européenne frugale et de
confiance à approfondir je vais centrer
mon propos autour de plusieurs axes le
premier c'est faire état en fait du
constat que nous avons porté sur la
formation dite initiale et le constat il
est le suivant on s'est fondé sur des
données fournies par le ministère de
l'Enseignement sup et de la recherche
sur lequel nous avons appliqué des
filtres particuliers sur la sémantique
de l'IA puisque vous n'êtes pas sans
savoir que la définition de l'IA peut
parfois être divergente en tout cas elle
est multiple elle est la combinaison en
fait d'algorithmes et de et de et de
méthodes appliquées à la algorithmique
aux données pour autant il est
extrêmement difficile de caractériser de
donner une définition très unique
ouivoque et très précise de l'IA donc
nous avons appliqué des filtrages c'est
un des apports en fait de cette
évaluation de politique publique menée
par la Cour et sur lesquels nous avons
constaté que en matière de formation
initiale il y a une forte croissance des
gens qui ont été formés en IA avec une
progression qui est majeure mais qui
demeure pour autant en deçà des enjeux
que nous connaissons tous sur
l'intelligence artificielle c'est une
formation Enya initiale qui est en
développement qui ne repose pas
uniquement sur les centres d'excellence
qui vous ont été présentés mais qui sont
bien diffusés j'allais dire dans
beaucoup d'universités françaises et
l'essentiel de cette offre sur l'IA et
essentiellement ciblé au niveau des
masters vous le constatez avec les
données Master Doctorat près de 17000
places en 2021 une progression 35% donc
extrêmement rapide par rapport à 2020
185 formations proposées en IA en 2021
une progression de 17% par rapport à
2020 et comme le disait Matthieu motion
callefebvre 556 thèses en Y a soutenu en
2017 19 pardon avec une augmentation de
10% qui est le reflet effectivement de
l'effort qui a été porté notamment par
la stratégie nationale en intelligence
artificielle pour soutenir les thèses et
les docteurs en intelligence
artificielle
un effort évident une prise de
conscience évident sur la nécessité de
former en formation initiale en
intelligence artificielle mais avec des
finalement en deçà des besoins réels en
la matière s'agissant de la formation
continue c'est l'autre volet une
formation continue en Yaki également
déficiente par rapport aux besoins
exprimés parce que insuffisamment
couvert et une faible mobilisation et
vous le voyez c'est assez parlant du de
l'enseignement public en matière de
formation continue la source nous
provient de la Caisse des dépôts et
consignations à partir de la source mon
compte formation puisque nous parlons de
formation continue alors que le secteur
privé en quelque sorte endossé cette
cette responsabilité en matière de
formation de formation continue donc des
besoins couverts pas suffisamment par
l'enseignement supérieur public mais en
revanche voilà une prise de conscience
également en la matière et pour faire le
lien finalement et faire l'interface
entre l'enseignement initial
l'enseignement continué mais également
avec l'enseignement secondaire puisqu'il
faut nous faut impérativement retourner
à la Source ce que nous avons constaté
c'est qu'il y a évidemment un enjeu
majeur de d'interface entre le scolaire
et le supérieur dans la mesure où il y a
une diffusion croissante mais qui reste
circonscrite de l'IA dans le secondaire
qui pourtant un enjeu de compétences
d'être activité et des viviers futurs
pourquoi parce qu'en fait ce sont les
filières de mathématiques les filières
de numérique et de sciences numériques
qui pourvoient finalement aux
enseignements et à la facilitation
finalement des des élèves formés en
intelligence artificielle et que ces
filières doivent absolument être
maintenues et entretenu pour pouvoir
garantir le succès futur et les filières
futures notamment dans l'enseignement
sup voir dans la recherche la question
de la parité pardon dans ces filières
scolaires permettant l'acquisition des
compétences mathématiques nécessaires à
liées à présente une trajectoire
préoccupante là également nous repartons
à la source c'est filières mathématiques
et informatique et numérique qui
pourvoit alia infinie présente
évidemment des déséquilibres en termes
de parité qui sont retrouvés en fait
dans la suite dans la suite de la de la
carrière scolaire ce déséquilibre
structurel évidemment entre femmes et
hommes formaient alia et susceptible de
renforcer les inégalités de façon plus
large dans la société évidemment en
raison de l'impact de l'IA sur
l'accompagnement à la prise de décision
recommande bien évidemment de fait du
fait de ces constats présentés de
réaliser une cartographie harmonisée
actualise des formations en IA à
valoriser au travers d'un label commun
pour les rendre visibles et accompagner
la massification et prévoir les besoins
en enseignant du secondaire bien
évidemment en enseignant chercheur nous
allons le voir et en chercheur formé à
l'usage de l'IA et établir des plantes
formations adéquates qui me permet de
faire la transition avec un autre
l'autre domaine qui est celui des
enseignants chercheurs et des chercheurs
qui la planche suivante
s'il y a les difficultés se posent pour
le secondaire et pour l'enseignement
supérieur évidemment la question se
porte également sur les enseignants
chercheurs et sur les chercheurs il y a
une nécessité d'avoir des formateurs en
a de haut niveau sur la période 2010
2019 les taux d'accroissement des
anciens niant chercheurs dans le domaine
de l'IA à seulement été de 4% contre
225% en docteur en IA c'est à dire qu'il
y a une comment dire un déséquilibre
entre des docteurs qui soutiennent leur
thèses qui dont le nombre a exploser et
dans le même temps les formateurs les
accompagnateurs les personnes en
capacité d'accompagner ces docteurs
notamment qui lui est en croissance
beaucoup plus faible et qui ne
permettent pas d'accompagner à la
hauteur finalement des ambitions portées
par les par les futurs chercheurs et les
futurs doctorants donc des efforts de
recrutement sont évidamment à consentir
en matière d'enseignants chercheurs et
de chercheurs pour autant des organismes
de recherche comme le CNRS ou l'INRIA
ont mis en place des dispositifs tout à
fait pertinents et particulier qui
permettent de garantir une attractivité
et et des chercheurs et notamment des
étudiants étrangers dont le constat que
cette attractivité par la France reste
encore fragile
pour le skier de l'état des lieux donc
du secondaire de l'enseignement sup et
de la Recherche
l'état des lieux vient de vous être
présenté je ferai juste un point en deux
volets sur ce que Marie Roger Vasselin
avait présenté comment je société que
nous avons regardé dans notre 4e
question évaluative à savoir finalement
est-ce que la stratégie a permis de
prendre en compte il y a dite de
confiance il y a dit de frugal il y a de
confiance c'est pour faire simple il y a
expliqué explicatif qui s'explique et il
y a frugal c'est une il n'y a économe
finalement dans ses ressources oui en
termes de de confiance des dispositifs
sont pris en considération et la
stratégie nationale de recherche a
permis de les mettre en oeuvre hors PEPR
donc je ne ferai pas la déclinaison de
ce qui vous est présenté mais des
dispositifs importants et des
financements ont bien été mis en oeuvre
et permettre de réorienter cette
stratégie vers davantage de prise en
considération de cette nécessité
d'accompagner lia et de pouvoir être en
capacité de l'expliquer
en revanche pour ce qui est de l'iadies
frugal c'est la planche suivante voilà
et je finirai mes propos ainsi sur l'IA
frugal nous avons procédé et ça ça fait
partie des méthodes qualitatives que
nous avons mises en oeuvre nous avons
procédé à un sondage auprès de la
communauté des chercheurs se réclamant
de l'intelligence artificielle la
consultation que nous avons pu mener
montre en fait finalement que il y a peu
de prise de conscience ou une maturité
encore faible de l'ensemble de
l'écosystème sur la question de la
frugalité de l'IA de son économie en
ressource et de la nécessité de
s'en emparer dans les recherches dans la
mise en oeuvre des supercalculateurs
voilà donc ce constat est assez flagrant
il repose sur cette évaluation et cette
cette ce questionnaire en fait cette
consultation que nous avons pu faire et
qui conduit la cour à recommander
finalement d'élaborer une charte et un
catalogue de bonnes pratiques visant à
définir et à suivre l'impact
environnemental de la recherche en IA et
à favoriser le développement du nia dite
responsable c'est-à-dire économe
quand on se compare on sera sûr on
s'inquiète
merci monsieur le Président
un petit peu les un petit peu les deux
la comparaison comment nous avons
procédé l'échantillon
est assez représentatif ce sont des
échantillons de
un échantillon de pays sur lequel on a
suffisamment de données donc
en Europe l'Allemagne les Pays-Bas
la Suisse l'Italie la Finlande on a
ajouté
les États-Unis bien sûr et le Canada qui
est très intéressant parce que le Canada
à cheval entre les les deux cultures
Israël bien sûr et le Japon donc au
total
10 la méthodologie
outre les calculs les graphiques qu'on
pouvait trouver
nous avons nous sommes passés par notre
réseau diplomatique et
économique et là c'était frappant de
voir à quel point ils avaient une bonne
connaissance et
ils ont pu nous approvisionner de donner
extrêmement précises c'est assez
remarquable je tiens à le souligner et
ça c'est quand les services de
coopération et d'action culturelle sont
bien dotées
et c'était assez exceptionnel alors les
les conclusions
tout ça fait l'objet d'un
volume à part parce que comme on a fait
quelque chose d'assez approfondie
une annexe et puis une synthèse d'une
trentaine de pages
trois conclusions
la première
bien prendre conscience
de qui a un premier groupe c'est les
États-Unis avec la concurrence de la
Chine
nous parlons là d'échelle de grandeur
vraiment très très différents de chaque
État membre de l'Union européenne c'est
c'est c'est vraiment
tout à fait
patent
la deuxième conclusion quand on regarde
les thèmes de la stratégie française et
et
avec
tous les commentaires qui qui ont été
dit et les conclusions auparavant sur la
nécessité de perfectionner
quand on regarde les autres pays en fait
les stratégies
par des mêmes thèmes et c'est en ça
monsieur le Président que je voulais
dire c'est rassurant on est bien dans le
cœur du sujet
les thèmes le renforcement d'un nombre
ciblé de centres de compétences c'est ce
qu'a dit Mathieu sur les quatria plus
les trois les trois centres tous font ça
il y a une stratégie partout de
concentration de matière grise dans des
centres particuliers pas forcément
d'ailleurs avec
quelque chose de juridique mais
rassembler rassembler des équipes les
programmes de création de chair
donc nous
les Allemands s'enchèrent vraiment
attirer
attirer les meilleurs et on n'attire pas
les mouches avec du vinaigre donc c'est
très important c'est très important le
Canada par exemple a une stratégie très
forte avec quelque chose qui n'est
50% des chers créés doivent venir de
gens qui viennent au Canada qui arrive
du canard donc
le développement de la formation
ça aussi c'est quelque chose
que Mathieu et Flora
on souligné c'est à dire qu'il faut le
vivier il faut le vivier qui fait monter
après les docteurs etc le développement
de capacité de calcul pour les
laboratoires de recherche publique et
ça c'est partout recherché Vous avez des
développements de capacité de calcul
dans le secteur privé Google etc mais
c'est absolument indispensable alors il
y a eu Jean Zay depuis on a annoncé
que la France allait héberger un centre
de calcul
européen quand on regarde les
classements parce qu'il y a un
classement des capacités de calcul ça
varie énormément
ça varie énormément de six mois en six
mois donc là il y a une véritable course
que j'appellerais une course aux
armements avec des investissements
énormes le renforcement de l'actrice
l'attractivité là je renvoie ce que je
disais sur l'échelle la coopération
partenariale internationale et là c'est
c'est un point important c'est à dire
qu'on est plus intelligent on y a quand
on travaille à plusieurs et avec
plusieurs cultures et toute la stratégie
que nous devons avoir c'est de
travailler avec les meilleurs
c'est-à-dire une stratégie ascendante
et la coopération attire la coopération
et la qualité attire la qualité le
transfert de résultats de la recherche
vers le monde économique ça c'est un
problème bien connu avec les les atouts
et les difficultés qu'on peut connaitre
et les règles d'usage et des normes
alors ça c'est le point important et
c'est plutôt une force je pense
l'action de l'Union européenne sur
toutes les règles d'usage
se renforcent
et je pense que l'Union européenne
a un avantage là dessus qui est toujours
lié au Full l'Union européenne c'est que
nous sommes 450 millions
donc c'est le marché de 450 millions
pour conclure et pour vous dire que
la course va s'accélérer et je pense que
c'est le message aussi que nous voulons
donner c'est à dire que faut pas lâcher
le manche ça va s'accélérer c'est
exponentiel
la loi de Moore
c'était un ingénieur
chimiste
il est mort en mars 2023
cette courbe
elle explique que les transistors dans
les puces
ça double tous les deux ans
donc c'est une c'est une ce qui vous
explique que par exemple l'année
dernière on a beaucoup mis l'accent dans
la presse sur la course à mort
sur les usines de fabrication des puces
et pas simplement sur les usines de
fabrication des puces mais sur les sur
les structures qui inventent le design
des puces avec le problème la question
centrale de Taïwan et où est-ce qu'on
met les usines voilà c'est c'est les
principales
conclusion mais la conclusion si j'avais
une chose à dire pour l'avenir c'est pas
simplement que ça va continuer mais ça
va s'accélérer
voilà monsieur le Président de la
présentation de son à disposition bien
sûr pour pour la résumer vous êtes tous
conscients de l'importance du sujet
c'est un sujet de de
qui impacte évidemment enfin qui est
terminera d'une certaine manière notre
souveraineté
nos dépendances bien entendu notre
compétitivité celle de nos entreprises
mais aussi l'excision de société vous en
êtes bien conscient et donc il est il
est il est central et il est important
et votre action y contribue sans doute
de de non seulement d'accompagner de
financer mais aussi de donner confiance
à la société pour que pour s'engager
dans ce dans cette compétition dans ce
défi nous sommes encore une fois nous
n'avons regardé que le la stratégie nous
sommes à l'étage supérieur si je puis
dire et encore une fois cette stratégie
évolue s'adapte donc nous n'excluons pas
du tout et je pense que nous ferons de
revenir sur ce sujet pour voir peut-être
l'année prochaine comment les choses
évoluent comme on ne recommandations
sont mises en oeuvre comment réagissent
les les autorités
ce qui est vrai c'est que c'est un défi
comparable en terme d'organisation tu as
opératif à ce que nous avons connu enfin
nos anciens avec l'aventure nucléaire
l'aventure spatiale l'aventure de la
santé tout est aussi important je n'ai
pas que c'est une priorité mais ce qui
me paraît important contenu pour
conclure par rapport au point
d'excellence que je citer en début de
propos de notre école scientifique de
notre école mathématique notamment c'est
de savoir si nous sommes capables de la
convertir or de ce point de vue nous
devons prendre à la fois la mesure des
impulsions et il y en a et il appartient
aux autorités au gouvernement de vous
convaincre que les les annonces que la
ministre de la Recherche madame
Retailleau fera le 11 septembre vont
dans la bonne direction vont faciliter
les choses bon mais aussi pour nous de
bien prendre la mesure des blocages de
ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui le
cosystème c'est-à-dire que vous aurez
peut-être des questions sur le sujet
mais l'intérieur artificielle n'est pas
traité différemment des autres
disciplines quand elle donne lieu
parfois une compétition pas toujours
positive parfois stérile entre organisme
quand elle doit être mise en œuvre dans
des organismes du monde de la recherche
qui sont eux-mêmes soumis à des règles
bureaucratiques vous voyez toutes ces
questions là donc si si on retient
l'idée que c'est à la fois centrale et
qu'il ne faut pas perdre de temps nous
avons nous un devoir d'information et
nous travaux essaierons de de vous en
convaincre au futur pour à la fois
prendra acte des initiatives heureuses à
juste temps mais aussi de la levée des
obstacles qui empêchent notre pays
d'avancer dans cette direction voilà
monsieur le Président merci pour cette
présentation très complète de vos
travaux on va commencer la série de
questions et je vais commencer donc au
nom de de l'or darkos qui souhaitait
vous interroger sur trois points donc je
vais les me faire son porte-voix votre
rapport montre à raison combien la
formulation d'une stratégie nationale de
recherche est importante c'est ce qui a
manqué à la LPR laquelle ne repose que
sur une programmation budgétaire nous
avions lors de l'examen du texte
déplorer cette lagune au-delà des
financements spécifiques alloués à cette
stratégie nationale de recherche en IA
avez-vous mesuré ou pu mesurer les
retombées financières de la LPE RPA donc
pour ce secteur bien sûr de lire
deuxième question vous pointez également
le manque de gouvernance et de pilotage
de la recherche en IA problématique que
nous avions déjà identifié pour la
recherche en santé lors de la crise de
la covid à quoi selon vous est dû ce
programme ce problème récurrent de
gouvernance dans le secteur de la
recherche
dans le domaine de l'IA comment
envisagez-vous l'articulation entre les
missions des universités et celles des
organismes de recherche
sujet assez classique
troisième série de questions votre
rapport soulève aussi à juste titre la
question des effectifs étudiants et
d'enseignants chercheurs vous l'avez
signalé de l'écosystème universitaire de
l'intelligence artificielle en pointant
deux principales difficultés première
difficulté le décalage entre la
croissance globalement dynamique plus de
30% en 6 ans des effectifs d'étudiants
et la stagnation des effectifs
d'enseignants chercheurs sur la même
période pour faire face à ce frein
potentiel au développement de la
recherche en IA vous appelez à prévoir
les besoins en enseignant chercheur
former à l'usage l'UA avez-vous procédé
à une évaluation chiffrée de ses besoins
seconde difficulté toujours sur cette
question de du Vivier le faible degré de
féminisation du secteur vous l'avez
aussi signalé 19,5% de femmes chez les
étudiants en mathématiques et en
informatique contre 57% dans l'ensemble
des disciplines 23% chez les enseignants
chercheurs en Y a cette problématique de
la place des femmes dans les sciences ne
tient particulièrement à cœur c'est
l'heure d'Archos qui parle mais je pense
qu'on peut en faire un pot collectif
j'avais tiré la sonnette d'alarme lors
de l'examen de la LPR mais les choses
évoluent peu je regrette que vous ne
formuliez pas de recommandation la
matière avez-vous néanmoins identifié
d'éveiller d'action je vous propose de
répondre d'abord à cette série de
questions et puis après mes collègues si
Monsieur Président je vais tenter puis
mes collègues complètement naturellement
bon sur le premier point où alors nous
nous donnera qu'effectivement qu'il n'y
a pas de stratégie nationale de
recherche depuis 2015 et que celle qui a
été arrêtée a été a été subi
intermittente et interrompu donc ça
n'est pas parce que nous avons une
stratégie nationale en matière d'intell
logiciel qui doit être évident mis à
jour qu'il n'y a pas un besoin de
stratégie nationale et nous sommes bien
d'accord dans nos constats avec ce que
Madame marcozy sur le fait que la loi de
programmation ne se substitue pas en
elle-même à une stratégie pour autant
cette loi de programmation de la
recherche de 2020 elle est en cours de
mise en œuvre les décrets d'application
ont été pris progressivement et nous
n'avons pas encore travaillé sur sur une
évaluation c'est une de réflexion
d'aller voir ce que donne donc deux
trois ans après cette loi donc je moi je
ne sois pas en mesure de mesurer nous
voyons bien en quoi par exemple la
création de chair de de de de docteur
junior peut faciliter répondre à la
troisième question de certaines manières
bon et rendre plus attractif les
fonctions de chercheurs que ça avec les
dispositifs intérieurs il n'est pas
encore possible dans mesurer les
retombées financières sur ce point je
sais pas si vous souhaitez compléter
mais voilà nous nous sommes prudents et
modestes mais mais il demeure il demeure
encore une fois à la fois un besoin
d'évaluer les le fait de cette loi de
programmation de la recherche et
probablement le besoin d'une stratégie
nationale plus globale dans laquelle ça
sert l'interne artificielle alors sur le
deuxième point le manque de gouvernance
alors le j'essaie de me faire le porteur
de la doctrine de la Cour des comptes
qui ne trahit pas sur tout et qui n'a
pas forcément une vision actualisée de
tous les sujets mais
vous le savez le modèle français de la
recherche c'est un peu faire une course
de haie quand d'autres font une course
de plat sans comparer avec telle ou tel
pays bon nous avons cette fameuse
double dualité
du dualité entre une recherche qui est
faite à peu près à parité d'ailleurs
dans le monde universitaire dans
l'université une recherche qui est fait
dans les organismes de recherche au sein
du monde de l'enseignement supérieur une
dualité entre les universités
stricto-sensus et les grandes écoles
c'est comme ça c'est notre histoire bon
mais mais on peut en être fier mais
c'est une complexité supplémentaire et
donc il y a vraiment un défi de de
gouvernance en effet de pilotage alors
plus précisément sur le sur
l'intelligence artificielle vous avez vu
que nous situons l'INRIA qui est un
organisme qui connaît quelques
difficultés de gouvernance actuellement
mais sur qu'elles n'ont pas travaillé
récemment pour être très très franc
c'est un c'est un organisme qui a doit
avoir et nous le recommandons une place
centrale pour autant bien évidemment
d'autres organismes et je n'ai pas même
pas des centres d'excellence mais il y a
des laboratoires du CNRS qui travaillent
sur l'intelligentiel et donc nous
revenons sur un sujet classique et le
sujet de l'arc la coordination
l'articulation par exemple des divers
des dizaines d'opérateurs nationaux de
recherche dont disposons en France le
sentiment mais c'est un sentiment
personnel car la Cour n'a pas travaillé
que j'ai c'est qu'il devrait y avoir un
alignement progressif il y a une mesure
disons positive ce sont les annonces que
devrait faire la ministre madame taillot
sur la base d'un rapport que vous
connaissez sans doute qui est le rapport
gilet qui a été remis le 15 juin on a
sur l'écosystème de la recherche alors
ça n'est pas sur l'intelligence
artificielle mais nous avons vu ça avec
grand intérêt dans la perspective de
cette de cette audition et d'ailleurs de
nos travaux bon que dit que propose le
professeur Gillet qu'est-ce que la
ministre dans ces quelques déclarations
et commentaires
risquent de retenir c'est la notion de
programme
l'agence de programme vous savez tout ce
que c'est que le CNES le CEA on est là
bon donc on n'a pas recréer une agence
spéciale pour l'intelligence
artificielle il semblerait mais c'est
évidemment au ministère de confirmer que
l'INRIA puisse être de manière plus
pleine qu'elle ne l'est aujourd'hui
cette agence de programme on parle d'une
dizaine d'agences de programme donc de
grandes thématiques de recherche sur le
champ de recherche et donc ce point de
vue il faut escompter mais attendons il
faut escompter que d'ici quelques mois
le Linera sera peut-être confortée dans
une mission de chef de fil pas
simplement d'opérateurs de recherche ou
d'agences de moyens qui permettra sans
doute de mieux structurer l'effort c'est
vrai dans ce domaine c'est vrai dans les
autres domaines alors pour autant il
faudra être attentif parce qu'en une
fois la gouvernance de ces organismes et
pour dire les choses la relative
faiblesse du ministère de l'enseignement
supérieur de la recherche dans ce
domaine en termes de tutelle de pilotage
ce sujet sur lequel nous pensons
travailler d'ailleurs dans les dans les
mois qui viennent
doit être aussi prise en compte sur le
troisième plan alors là je sais toute la
parole sur les questions d'effectif
d'enseignement chercheurs et de
féminisation je sais pas si Flora va
intervenir
des effectifs et de la question du
diagnostic que nous aurions pu établir
sur les besoins en enseignant chercheur
et en chercheur en matière de Dia nous
n'y avons pas procédé nous avons pas été
en capacité de mener ce travail en tout
cas jusqu'à jusqu'à ce terme pour autant
je tiens à préciser que l'appel à
manifestation d'intérêt sur dit CMA
compétences et métiers d'avenir à dans
un de ses volets enfin il a deux volets
diagnostics et il sera amené à poser ce
diagnostic du besoin futur des
enseignants chercheurs et des chercheurs
à former et pour pouvoir permettre de de
faire monter en compétences et monter en
puissance les nombreux étudiants dans le
domaine donc la mi-cma devrait pouvoir
répondre à cette question de
l'établissement du nombre d'enseignants
chercheurs et de chercheurs pour
l'avenir
merci je vais prendre maintenant vos
questions en commençant par celles de
Stéphane piennois qui est rapporteur
pour avis des crédits budgétaires sur
l'enseignement supérieur
merci monsieur le Président Madame et
messieurs merci pour la présentation de
votre rapport sur un sujet qui
qui passionne qui est relativement
nouveau et qui passionne qui intrigue
qui qui inquiète même parfois thème de
l'intelligence artificielle la prise de
contrôle des robots sur l'activité
humaine alors on cite souvent le
l'automobile mais il y a d'autres
domaines dans lesquels on est un tout
petit peu plus inquiet déjà l'automobile
inquiète alors le message politique que
vous faites de préférence avec cette
stratégie nationale sur l'intelligence
artificielle est évidemment importante
on a vu que l'impulsion il y a une
certaine impulsion dans plusieurs
domaines mais il me semble que le
financement et au moins aussi important
et moi il y a quelque chose qui qui m'a
choqué qui m'a frappé en tout cas dès le
début dans votre propos dans votre
présentation c'est que sur les le 1
milliard 5 annoncé comme plan et on a la
comment dire une forte capacité en
France à annoncer des plans avec des
financements à côté
en réalité vous avez dit 9% seulement de
crédit budgétaire nouveau 9 % alors on
peut se dire on a 445 millions qui sont
fléchés sur la recherche 128 sur
l'enseignement supérieur si on réduit ça
à 9 % j'aimerais savoir exactement à
quoi correspond comme crédit nouveau sur
la recherche sur l'enseignement
supérieur dont on a vu que c'était un
élément essentiel d'impulsion pour les
thèses évidemment pour le nombre
d'étudiants inscrits en master et
doctorat donc vraiment une demande forte
de de recherche des traces
d'un document en dur d'un document
budgétaire qui donne les crédits
nouveaux de ce plan
ensuite je crois que lors d'Archos mit a
fait allusion on a voté il y a quelques
années maintenant la loi de
programmation de la recherche
est-ce que là encore ce qui est pas une
forme de doublon en disant on a une LPR
qui veut
accentuer qui veut donner des impulsions
sur des
thématiques qui sont porteuses
actuellement quel est l'effet ce que
vous avez pu mesurer l'effet réel de
cette des financements nouveaux sur la
LPR là aussi on s'était bagarré pour
avoir la trace des financements nouveaux
difficile troisième point pour pour moi
est-ce que vous avez réussi à
différencier ce qui relève justement de
du message politique et du financement
associé et non parce que ce qui est un
effet de mode mais ce qui est un effet
d'intérêt nouveau pour une discipline
pour un champ de disciplinaire qui est
relativement nouveau c'est c'est on voit
bien que l'impulsion sur le nombre de
thèses est-ce qu'il est directement
corrélé au financement ou finalement
est-ce qu'il est corrélé à une nouvelle
un nouvel axe de recherche mondialement
référencé
et puis
alors sur les implantations je vous ai
entendu dire cette pôles d'excellence
l'intelligence artificielle 7 4 en
région parisienne est-ce qu'il y a un
questionnement sur la répartition vous
savez dans toute la France en dehors de
Paris dans toute la France qui pourrait
accueillir aussi des pôles est-ce que
c'est un des axes de ce de ce plan et
puis dernier point qui m'est cher sur
évidemment le lien avec les
mathématiques je vous ai entendu dire je
suis ancien professeur de maths
vous avez dit c'est l'école l'école
d'excellence mathématiques qui qui
finalement alimente ce secteur de
l'intelligence artificielle il y a un
truc qui me semble absolument pas
totalement absent de votre propos et qui
me semble absolument fondamental dans
l'impact que ça peut avoir c'est la
réforme du bac
c'est la réforme du bac aujourd'hui les
écoles d'ingénieurs se plaignent d'une
baisse dramatique en quelques en deux
ans
vous savez pas les vieux profs qui
disent au bout de 15 ans de carrière le
niveau baisse non non ceux qui sont là
depuis deux ans qui disent mais cette
réforme du bac a un impact absolument
considérable sur le niveau de sortie des
élèves de lycée l'entrée dans les écoles
d'ingénieurs tout est à refaire ou
presque alors je sais que votre votre
rapport consiste à finalement sur la
conclusion on pourrait dire c'est mieux
que si c'était pire mais dans ce domaine
là j'ai l'impression que c'est quand
même pire
je vais prendre toutes les questions
comme ça
pierre rouzouillas pardon merci monsieur
le Président mais mesdames messieurs
merci pour pour la qualité de votre
rapport et je dois vous dire avec
beaucoup de sincérité que j'apprécie
toujours de lire vos contributions la
dernière sur l'université était vraiment
extrêmement
intéressantes je partage votre votre
volonté de faire que la Cour des comptes
puisse être saisie de façon plus souvent
par plus plus fréquente par par le Sénat
mais je parle sous votre contrôle
monsieur le Président je crois je crois
que c'est nous c'est nous c'est plutôt
la commission des finances qui désigne
qui décident d'une saisine vers la Cour
des comptes alors je me permets cette
insolence monsieur le Président mais
peut-être que un petit rapport sur la
science ouverte qui est pas son rapport
avec l'intelligence artificielle ça
pourrait être intéressant parce que là
il y a une évolution de la dépense qui
qui pose problème voilà
vous vous avez parlé du rapport gilet et
je vois avec ce rapport beaucoup de
convergence dans le travail que vous
avez fait la première c'est la nécessité
de repenser le temps long et de
considérer que dans des domaines aussi
particuliers que celui-là si les efforts
sont pas maintenus pendant plusieurs
années voire plusieurs dizaines d'années
on n'arrive pas à déboucher sur des
révolutions paradigmatiques ce qui est
quand même l'objectif et dans le rapport
gilet il y a très nettement une demande
de rééquilibrage entre les appels sur
projets et les financements de base je
pense que c'est tout à fait important
dans le rapport gilet il y a la même
constatation que celle que vous faites
c'est à dire l'absence de stratégie
nationale
Philippe Gillet dit très justement que
une stratégie de recherche nationale
c'est pas l'empilement de stratégie
sectorielle mais c'est quelque chose de
tout à fait autre et je remarque que en
plus de la dualité que vous avez
soulignée entre l'enseignement supérieur
et la recherche c'est rajouter le
secrétaire général pour l'investissement
qui a 50 milliards pour pour investir
dans l'innovation et dans la recherche
même si on n'a pas toujours compris
quelle était la part recherche dans ces
50 milliards donc on rajoute un
troisième opérateur plus la NR ça fait
un quatrième et on sent très bien que il
y a un manque de cohérence totale le
rapport gelé comme vous l'avez dit
considère que la tâche de gestionnaire
de programme pour être confiée à des
opérateurs de recherche l'INRIA ma
question serait est-ce qu'ils ont les
moyens eux seuls de définir une
programmation de la recherche où est-ce
qu'on doit les considérer comme les
agences de mise en œuvre
d'une stratégie qui est conçue ailleurs
avec d'autres d'autres opérateurs par
ailleurs dans la relation que nous avons
avec les gafam nous avons de grands
handicaps et le premier handicap c'est
le salaire des chercheurs
quand vous passez du CNRS à Google par
exemple vous rajoutez un zéro sur votre
bulletin de salaire de voilà vous voyez
je retarde déjà c'est c'est considérable
et donc je pense pas je crois pas que on
puisse offrir dans la fonction publique
des salaires équivalents à ceux de
Google mais qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
pour d'abord garder les chercheurs
français et en attiré d'autres si c'est
pas le salaire ça doit être autre chose
ça doit être l'environnement de la
recherche les infrastructures comme vous
l'avez vous l'avez très justement et là
moi je ne sens pas d'évolution les
chartes de professeurs junior on voit
très bien quel but sur ce même problème
c'est ce qui est ce qui est important
c'est surtout l'environnement et enfin
ma troisième question elle concerne ce
que nous sommes un train de gérer au
sénancement c'est-à-dire l'espace
numérique et on voit très bien que
l'intelligence artificielle elle a
besoin de se nourrir de quantité
de données que d'autres nations je pense
à la Chine arrive à se procurer en
oubliant le sgpd et un certain nombre de
règles éthiques donc comment nous
pouvons faire tout en restant dans le
cadre défini par l'Europe et que je
défends complètement pour que les
données publiques puissent mieux
profiter à la recherche et là on sent
qu'il y a une mobilisation
pluri-institutionnelle plurid
ministérielle pour permettre un plus
grand accès des données publiques à leur
à la recherche voilà c'était les trois
questions que je voulais vous poser
merci monsieur le Président Bernard
fialer
merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur dame moi c'est simplement une
précision que j'aimerais avoir vous
savez parler
finalement de la désaffection des
étudiants étrangers pour venir pour
venir en France moi j'aimerais bien que
vous revenir sur que vous disiez un
petit peu plus ou est-ce qu'ils vont
parce que l'intelligence artificielle
elle se nourrit à l'émerge de des
mathématiques qui ont quand même les
mathématiques françaises en rayonnement
international important et comment on
explique qu'il n'y ait pas plus
d'étudiants étrangers qui soient
intéressés pour venir étudier dans dans
ce domaine et où vont-ils est-ce qu'ils
vont certaine destinations on peut
l'imaginer les États-Unis mais en Europe
est-ce qu'il y a des pays qui savent
mieux faire que nous
Monique de Marco
oui je vous remercie je vous remercie de
cette exposé très intéressante je
partage les remarques de mon collègue
Stéphane pietnoir sur les conséquences
de la réforme du bac et je rajouterai
je vous le rappelle la suppression de la
technologie en 6e dans les collèges qui
finalement auront des conséquences pour
le futur de ses élèves pour les choix et
les orientations alors ma question est
plutôt sur une remarque que je vous
demande si vous pouvez compléter en
termes de moyens financiers et une
mobilisation des chercheurs ce qui
concerne l'IA frugal et son impact
environnemental est-ce que vous avez
détaillé un petit peu ces
différentes sections et peut-être aussi
il y a de confiance vous en avez très
peu très peu parlé
voilà je vous remercie
oui merci monsieur le Président merci
pour la présentation de ce rapport alors
vous avez dit beaucoup de choses sur les
synergies qui pourraient être organisées
mais une des recommandations du rapport
c'est le renforcement des synergies
entre les pôles d'excellence et
l'intelligence artificielle cette
recommandation suggère que les
collaborations et la coordination entre
les pôles puissent être améliorés est-ce
que vous pouvez nous donner quelques
détails sur les actions concrètes
envisagées pour atteindre cet objectif
et comment envisagez-vous de facilité la
collaboration entre et encourager la
collaboration entre les différents pôles
et une deuxième question on a parlé de
programme européen votre rapport indique
que la France doit améliorer son
intégration dans les programmes de
soutien européen comme horizon Europe et
pour une Europe numérique ces programmes
offrent des opportunités importantes
pour le développement de la recherche en
intelligence artificielle quelles sont
les mesures envisagées pour améliorer
l'intégration de la France dans ces
programmes et comment comptez-vous
faciliter la participation de chercheurs
français à ces programmes
voilà je vais vous laisser répondre à
toutes les séries de questions beaucoup
Monsieur président merci mesdames
messieurs on va se partager évidemment
les réponses alors je vais reprendre ça
dans l'ordre les questions d'abord de
Monsieur piénoir alors quelle est la
part additionnelle de crédit véritable
je ne sais pas si l'un de mes collègues
peut répondre cet effet marginal
finalement Flora
[Musique]
sur les financements on n'a pas de
documents de référence sur sur 9% en
fait ce que ce qu'on a fait c'est qu'on
a travaillé avec les données donc
transmises par la coordination nationale
donc il mettait en évidence les
redéploiements budgétaires et les
crédits nouveaux et c'est des données
ensuite que nous on a retravaillé et
contre expertisé si je peux dire en
changeant parfois leur périmètre en
fonction de la mise en oeuvre de la
stratégie par exemple les grands défis
au départ c'était inclus dans le volet
recherche de à la stratégie nationale en
intelligence artificielle après ça a été
exclu finalement parce qu'on s'est dit
que c'était plutôt sur le volet
économique et donc c'est on les a nous
aussi exclus du périmètre mais ensuite
on n'a pas forcément de traces de
l'exécution directe de ses financements
et de commençons à louer ces 9% parce
que ça ça passe par les programmes
budgétaires et notamment le programme
172 et donc c'est comme ça qu'ils ont
qu'ils ont été abandonnés
alors sur l'autre volet de votre
question qui est l'effet financier de la
LPR bon vous savez évidemment que la
France de manière globale est plutôt en
décalage par rapport
aux membres de l'OCDE par exemple en
termes d'effort de recherche et
développement et de dépenses publiques
singulièrement il y a une ambition de
ratapage dans cette loi de programmation
sur 10 ans alors il faudra là il faudra
la suivre mais pour être concret nous
voyons déjà l'effet sur la NR alors la
NR c'est pas que l'intelligence
artificielle mais la NR le milliard
additionnel qui est qui est promis à la
NR permet en gros les chiffres sont très
approximatifs excusez-moi mais de passer
d'environ 800 millions par an un
milliard pour des financer des appels à
projets des activités de nature voilà
donc ça c'est concret donc il y a déjà
une inflexion depuis 2020 encore une
fois les lois sont plus grand respect
pour ce que vous votez mais vous savez
bien qu'il faut que ce soit mis en
oeuvre par les administrations les
décrets etc donc ça n'est pas il faut un
petit temps et nous nous proposons ce
n'est pas l'engagement ferme que je
pense je suis en de le faire d'ailleurs
ça relève du point président mais nous
proposons vraiment d'aller voir la LPR
si on a les moyens l'année prochaine
pour voir pour pouvoir vous rendre
compte et rendre compte de citoyens de
la manière dont les choses avancent et
se sont mises en oeuvre pour
l'intelligence artificielle comme pour
les autres disciplines scientifiques
alors sur la question monsieur je vais
pas m'attendrai pas parler de procédures
puisque c'était votre votre introduction
je peux vous confirmer quand même c'est
l'histoire des saisines de la cour que
bien sûr les commissions des finances
sont compétentes au titre de l'article
58 2 de la LOLF pour nous passer des des
commandes voilà donc c'est des
contributions mais pour ce qui est de
l'évaluation il n'y a pas de il n'y a
pas de règle particulière et simplement
l'Assemblée nationale a créé une
structure propre qui s'appelle le comité
d'évasion et le contrôle qui produit par
le président d'assemblée mais il est pas
dit qu'il doit y avoir une structure
c'est vraiment vous vos affaires si je
puis dire ça à vous de voir en tout cas
il y a pas de il y a pas de difficulté
particulière qui soit dans la loi et qui
et qui qui préviennent votre commission
ou une autre commission ou notre
instance de du Sénat de de nous passer
une commande d'évaluation de politique
publique si vous voulez vous passer une
commande sur la LPR je serai évidemment
tout à fait tout à fait tout à fait ravi
si les formes les formes évidemment les
procédures sont respectées alors ce
rapport gilet bon on va pas commenter
oui
enfin nous ce qui nous intéresse c'est
un rapport très intéressant qui se passe
du point de l'écosystème de la recherche
alors le problème c'est aussi
l'enseignement supérieur donc il y a un
angle dans le rapport gilet mais il est
utile bien sûr et mais c'est un rapport
et donc nous sommes prudents nous
attendons évidemment que que les autres
gouvernementales et la ministre prennent
position comme elle l'a dit je crois
comprendre que ça va être plus sur la
base de proposition d'expérimentation
sur un centre de sujets voilà donc je
pense qu'il faut il faut il faut garder
un intérêt mais effectivement il y a des
bonnes si vous voulez ce que de manière
plus et ça répond à plusieurs de vos
questions ce que nous observons et moi
je suis un observateur de fresh date
c'est que nous avons comme un système
qui est très cristallisé et très
bureaucratisé alors c'est facile de le
dire dans cet instant mais nous avons
travaillé par exemple sur les UMR vous
savez tous que sont les humains on sait
même pas les compter d'ailleurs il y en
a plusieurs milliers plus d'un millier
qui qui met le CRS en participation avec
les universités c'est
fallait pas les inventer c'est à dire
que c'est la gestion concrète et si vous
auditionnez les chercheurs la gestion
concrète d'une UMR vous en êtes
peut-être vous-même avec une sorte de
double système de responsabilité de
comptabilité etc c'est quelque chose il
faut en sortir c'est dans rapprocher
mais il faut sortir vous voyez c'est ça
vaut pour l'intelligence artificielle ça
vaut pour tout le reste donc
l'écosystème en question joue pour
savoir si nous allons être capable de
transformer cet essai nous avons une
stratégie qui comme ça a été montré a
été adopté plutôt que les autres mais si
si on est capable de ne pas perdre de
terrain ou ne pas s'engluer dans une
espèce de de voilà de marécage
bureaucratique je crois qu'il y a des
mesures très concrètes qui sont pas
toujours très simples ce que vous disiez
également sur le sur l'attractivité ou
sur les conditions des enseignants
chercheurs à la fois les conditions
rémunération alors je pense pas qu'on
puisse s'aligner avec Google mais mais
aussi comme vous l'avez très bien dit je
peux pas dire plus de choses leur
environnement professionnel les
conditions matérielles nous avons des
exemples enfin tombé dans l'anecdote ici
mais mais de cette nature alors je me
permets de d'utiliser votre question
pour compléter aussi à la question
monsieur fialer et de laisser mon
collègue François Saint-Paul vous
répondre la question de l'attractivité
comment rendre
les dragibus vis-à-vis notamment des
chercheurs étrangers nous allons alors
François Saint-Paul est chargé alors je
vous dis vraiment ce qu'on va faire
d'une enquête que nous lançons une
évaluation sur l'attractivité de la
France pour les étudiants étrangers mais
ça comprend les docteurs enfin ceux qui
viennent faire des études doctorat et
donc n'ont pas de résultats il faudra
nous inviter l'année prochaine si vous
le souhaitez mais peut-être que François
peut compléter qu'est-ce qui fait qu'on
n'est pas aussi attractif que d'autres
Européens
merci
dans les
classements et ça dépend ce qu'on
ce qu'on entend par étudiant étrangers
parce que il y a les étudiants qui sont
en formation diplômante il y a les
étudiants qui sont en formation
d'échange les cts
Erasmus puis vous avez aussi
les étudiants étrangers non mobiles qui
sont qui sont déjà en France
en gros
si on lance on compte tout on en est à
400 000 étudiants étrangers en France
alors nous sommes en train comme l'a dit
le président d'engager une évaluation de
politique publique sur l'attractivité
de l'espace d'enseignement supérieur en
France pour la pour l'accueil des
étudiants étrangers en France donc
une réponse beaucoup plus détaillée dans
dans un an je dirais voilà
pour mais je vais citer quand même
un exemple de chiffres que que j'ai en
mémoire
où vont les étudiants
étrangers pour prendre les formations
entre docteur
master licence 39%
des des doctorants
en France
sont des docteurs des doctorants
étrangers il y a un enjeu comme vous
dites tout à fait alimenter nos
laboratoires de recherche
rendez-vous dans
mais c'est vrai vous savez bien que
dans certains discipline nous avons
besoin de 6plin scientifique médicale
évidemment nous avons besoin de ces
chercheurs étrangers comme apport sinon
nous n'allons pas les effectifs des
laboratoires donc il y a aussi enfin
voilà un enjeu un enjeu d'attractivité
former des docteurs les conserver voilà
donc c'est important vous voulez
peut-être un point que je n'ai pas
répondu
sur la question du modèle des règles
éthiques bon là je crois qu'il y a un
enjeu enfin ça nous dépasse mais vous
situez les Gafa nous sommes déjà dans
les béatx donc
et c'est prolon seulement à l'échelle
européenne vous l'avez dit vous-même que
on peut essayer de concevoir une IA
respectueuse de ce que nous sommes ni à
démocratique si je puis dire avec des et
je crois que c'est à la fois bon c'est
pas moi dire que c'est le reflet de
notre modèle le souverainetre mais aussi
c'est une manière de rassurer les
citoyens si nous voulons que les
citoyens consent à financer consente à
investir comme vous le proposez il faut
leur il faut répondre à ces angoisses de
début de siècle ou siècle voilà enfin
des vrais sujets des vrais sujets voilà
donc est-ce qu'on est capable de définir
ce modèle en Union européenne comme le
disait François Saint-Paul si si active
voilà je crois que c'est une manière
aussi d'opposer ça cette cette mécanique
notamment chinoise sur les sur les
questions de sur les questions
d'attractivité pour apporter quelques
précisions et pour balancer un peu le
propos vous dire que il y a des motifs
d'attractivité de la France pour les
étudiants parce qu'en fait nous les
avons interviewé comme nous avons fait
le tour des centres d'excellence les
quatre troisia et les centres
d'excellence et nous avons panélisé en
fait et notamment les étudiants
étrangers nous avons recueilli leurs
propos les conditions les conditions
favorables d'être activités de la France
sont quand même la qualité de nos
universités la réputation de l'école de
mathématiques les conditions d'accueil
et les conditions la mise à disposition
d'équipements de recherche et notamment
l'accès à des supercalculateurs j'allais
dire les les bémols à la capacité d'être
activité c'est parfois la barrière de la
langue avec l'anglais qui reste quand
même qui bien sûr une langue de travail
et d'enseignement mais qui mériterait
d'être encore davantage je porte là les
propos le retour des propos de des
paroles des étudiants étrangères
interviewés mais voilà la barrière de la
langue peut-être un frein finalement
l'attractivité de la France le
développement encore insuffisant des
enseignements en anglais et la
difficulté à le faire en français voilà
ça peut faire partie dans les les points
positifs également finalement le le coup
assez intéressant pour eux du le coût de
la formation en France qui reste plus
compétitif que certains autres pays qui
restent des pays attractifs vous
demandiez lesquels bien évidemment les
États-Unis mais également la
Grande-Bretagne sont des pays qui
attirent l'Allemagne sont des pays qui
attirent voilà le j'allais pas dire la
modicité des coûts de formation en
France mais pour autant ça reste quand
même un facteur d'attractivité pour des
étudiants étrangers qui trouvent se
retrouve à venir ici dans des conditions
tout à fait remarquables et à des coûts
à des coûts pour eux raisonnables voilà
je me fais le le porte-parole de leur de
leur propos recueillis lors de leur de
notre tour de France même si j'ai bien
été effectivement la question de la
concentration des des notamment des
centres d'excellence au-delà des des
instituts 4e qui sont un petit peu mieux
répartis mais effectivement la
concentration parisienne de high Paris
Sky et dataïa sur sur Paris
la décision vous dites la barrière de la
langue que l'Allemagne devant nous qui a
pas l'école de la réputation de l'école
mathématiques je suis pas sûr que
l'allemand soit beaucoup plus diffusée
dans le monde que le français
sont plus sont plus assurés dans les on
a eu l'occasion de se déplacer notamment
en Allemagne sous la sous le la houlette
de François Saint-Paul je parle bien de
la diffusion de l'enseignement en langue
anglaise voilà c'est et en Allemagne
forcément est un peu plus garantie que
en France même si elle n'est pas du tout
à négligée il y a ne tenait pas de mon
propos le fait qu'on n'enseigne pas en
anglais en France on le fait voilà il y
a aucun mais c'est c'est un des éléments
de de barrière évoqués par les par les
étudiants étrangers
Flora ou Marie vous pouvez peut-être
répondre la première il y a le sujet de
comment on favoriser la féminisation
est-ce qu'on a des pistes je suis pas
sûr qu'on est fait d'ailleurs
conventions là-dessus et l'autre aspect
Marie est-ce qu'on est capable de
chiffrer ce qui relève du du frugal et
de la confiance dans l'IA est-ce que
est-ce que il y a des financements
fléchés est-ce qu'on est capable de dire
ce que ça représente
je vais prendre répondre sur la sur la
seconde question
il y a des financements effectivement
sur l'IA de confiance qui sont fléchés
là dessus donc on a rappelé donc dans le
dans le rapport il y a
10 millions donc dans le programme qui
sont prévus par le programme de
recherche
confiance à i donc dans le cadre des
grands défis il y a aussi 30 millions
donc qui sont prévus
pour la réalisation de démonstrateurs de
confiance en
IA donc dans des filières stratégiques
l'automobile aéronautique l'énergie le
chaînage d'assemblage et après il y a
aussi une stratégie de normalisation de
l'IA de confiance donc où là il y a 1,6
millions d'euros qui donc qui sont qui
sont prévus
ça c'est hors orpe et après il y a le
PEP r donc il y a l'IA de confiance et
il y a frugal comme objectif notamment
le peper c'est 73 millions d'euros il me
il y a pas de distinction en tout cas au
moment où on a fait nos travaux il y
avait pas de
vous pouvez pas identifier donc ce qui
allait vraiment aller sur l'IA de
confiance et sur le lien frugal donc je
peux pas vous répondre là dessus en
revanche sur sur l'iafrugal au-delà des
financements qui sont allés il y a quand
même un enjeu de de faire monter en
maturité si je puis dire la communauté
scientifique sur ces aspects là parce
que même sans financement on peut aussi
favoriser la diffusion de lit à frugal
quand on rencontrait les les chercheurs
dont certains étaient très sensibilisés
à ces enjeux mais vous avez vu que le
sondage montre que c'est pas le cas de
tous certains nous disaient on n'a pas
besoin toujours d'utiliser
l'intelligence artificielle et
aujourd'hui il peut y avoir des réflexes
même pour des résultats simples on
n'aurait pas forcément besoin d'utiliser
des capacités intensives en calcul
d'utiliser de l'intelligence
artificielle de mettre de l'intelligence
artificielle un peu partout donc il y a
aussi un enjeu de sensibiliser les
chercheurs là-dessus pour que même dans
leur pratique ils puissent intégrer
ce qui est ce qui va permettre de leur
donner un résultat plus efficace
possible mais aussi qui nécessite pas de
sortir l'artillerie lourde si je puis
dire alors qu'on pourrait faire ça par
un algorithme simple sans forcément être
très intensif en quelques je sais pas si
j'ai répondu à votre question
alors sur les différentes questions donc
notamment il y avait la question de
disparités de genre qui ont été
observées par la Cour lors de
l'instruction donc on a c'est des points
qui ont été soumis à la Direction
Générale de l'Enseignement scolaire et à
partir de la page 214 du rapport vous
avez des réponses très détaillées de des
actions qui ont été proposées par la DG
SCO notamment pour réduire ses
disparités de genre il y a aussi des
éléments sur le renforcement de la trade
la spécificité mathématique donc
évidemment c'est pas des points qu'on a
évalué dans le cadre de l'évaluation
parce que c'est des choses qui nous ont
été annoncées de façon concomitante mais
sera intéressant de suivre de suivre
l'impact de ces mesures dans l'avenir et
après il y avait différentes questions
donc il y avait une question sur les
disparités territoriales la répartition
territoriale des différentes mesures
donc peut-être en complément des pôles
d'excellence donc des 7 il y a aussi une
stratégie de chair hors troisia qui a
été mis en oeuvre donc ça c'est détaillé
page 57 58 dans le rapport vous avez
tous les chiffres ou en complément de
ces grands ces grands effets de
concentration il y a aussi une stratégie
beaucoup plus de cas permis de valoriser
des chercheurs et petites équipes
réparties sur le territoire et donc
notamment vous avez une carte toute une
carte qui montre que ça a permis de
couvrir d'autres bassins
territoriaux donc ça c'était un autre
élément de la stratégie qui a été qui a
été analysé donc sur lequel il y a eu du
coup une des ressources qui finalement
ont pu être aussi répartis
et après il y avait la question des
synergies entre les différents instituts
d'excellence donc dans le cas notamment
du deuxième volet donc le volet sur la
massification de l'intelligence
artificielle il y a des enjeux commun de
formation notamment qui ont été
identifiés et donc dans le cadre de
l'appel manifestation d'intérêt
compétences et métiers d'avenir il y a
une école d'intelligence artificielle et
Célia qui a été mise en oeuvre qui va
permettre de mobiliser le réseau en fait
pour pour massifier les formations ça
c'est un exemple d'action je crois avoir
vu aussi en Île-de-France des actions
qui ont été mis en œuvre entre dans le
domaine d'intérêts majeurs pour
justement fédérer les quatre instituts
franciliens notamment sur les enjeux de
formation doctorales donc voilà il y a
des choses qui sont en train de se
mettre en place
terminé donc la question de toujours
monsieur Levi sur la dimension
européenne alors je vais laisser
François donner quelques éléments mais
on est convaincu et je disais au
président que nous avons l'intention et
pardon de nous faire des annonces encore
une fois il faudra tenir nous avons le
sentiment que notre écosystème de
recherche et ça vaut pour les
universités ne sont pas à même de tirer
parti de tirer parti des financements
européens donc il y a un problème de
mobilisation pour des raisons qui
tiennent souvent à la lourdeur la
bureaucratie on peut d'équipements des
laboratoires ça ça nous allons le
regarder donc on peut pas vous répondre
mais ça c'est le ça vaut pour tout alors
peut-être que sur le sur horizon Europe
ou sur le dans le domaine de
l'intelligence artificielle François
peut ajouter quelque chose
merci monsieur le Président sur ça je
voudrais attirer l'attention sur la
deuxième partie de la note de synthèse
qui a dans le chapitre c'est l'Union
européenne intervient de façon
croissante pour réguler l'usage financer
la recherche poser les nouvelles règles
pour la gestion des données européennes
très très important il favoriser
l'hébergence de champion européens
industriels donc là vous vous aurez un
peu une description de l'ensemble de la
chaîne
où
l'Union européenne intervient
sur la recherche il y a une différence
bien sûr comme l'a dit le président avec
la Chine
mais il y a aussi une différence
d'approche avec les États-Unis
c'est-à-dire que aux États-Unis
c'est l'idée qu'on appelle
la light touch c'est à dire
empreinte faible sur la réglementation
pour ne pas
gêner
la recherche
ou en Europe c'est une c'est une autre
approche
qui correspond beaucoup plus au Medel
économique et sociétale européen
alors ça se traduit par quoi par exemple
aux États-Unis il y a pas d'une approche
pour une réglementation générale de de
l'IA
en Europe oui il y a un projet
actuellement de nouvelles
réglementations qui classent les usages
interdits dangereux soumis autorisations
etc ça c'est c'est très différent
au départ et je serai très court les
États-Unis étaient très sceptiques sur
l'approche européenne on a les Gafa on a
la puissance de feu économique on a la
puissance de feu financière on va
s'immerger tout ça
c'était sans compter sur deux choses la
première chose la volonté politique
et le fait qu'on est capable de faire
des propositions et deuxièmement la
différence sociétale
le résultat
les gafam et les Américains ont été si
vous me permettez l'expression
estomaquée par le DSA et le DMA le
digital services actes et le digital
market acte
il ne croyait pas en un an tout ça a été
adopté et aujourd'hui on envoie les
faits avec toute la difficulté de la
mise en œuvre
mais dans les événements qu'on a connu
par exemple quid de la surveillance des
plateformes sur la diffusion des images
et là ça renvoie à l'utilisation de l'IA
comme mécanisme de contrôle à mettre en
place par les plateformes pour faire un
peu le ménage par exemple voilà un point
important c'est la question de l'accord
que nous recherchons avec les États-Unis
sur le partage des données qui est un
vieux serpent de mer
entre les transatlantiques
et
moi je suis persuadé que dans les à
titre personnels dans les prochaines
perspectives financières qui vont suivre
après 2027 de bord les réflexions elles
vont commencer 2025 parce que
la part de ce qui est aujourd'hui
horizon Europe
va encore augmenter
et conclure tout à fait quelques
chiffres ça le l'Union européenne et sa
réponse à la nécessité de mobiliser
d'être nous capable de oui ces crédits a
prévu de consentir 10 milliards d'euros
pour l'intelligence artificielle sur la
période d'ici 2027 bon voilà je ne peux
pas vous dire que la part de la France
mais c'est un défi et c'est souvent
regardez comment dans ce domaine je sais
pas si Marie de compter
justement sur la partie
pour répondre au diagnostic qu'on fait
sur le fait qu'on pourrait capitaliser
davantage sur les financements européens
et donc sur les moyens
qu'on pourrait mettre en oeuvre pour
capitaliser davantage sur ses
financements la réponse peut être un peu
décevante c'est-à-dire qu'on n'a pas de
forcément de de réponse directement à
cette question mais néanmoins on
trouvait que c'était intéressant de
faire ce diagnostic et de mettre en
évidence parce que cette
cette part elle avait jamais été mise en
évidence de mettre en évidence le fait
que l'intelligence artificielle c'était
quand même une priorité du programme
Horizon 20 20
le diagnostic c'est que dans sa mise en
oeuvre la France a sur les projets donc
qui était qui concernait l'intelligence
artificielle on a eu à chaque fois entre
16 et 13 entre 7 pardon et 13% donc des
crédits qui étaient alloués à
l'intelligence artificielle sur ce
programme et donc un des objectifs dans
le cadre de la mise en oeuvre de horizon
Europe pour la coordination nationale de
la stratégie ça pourrait être de suivre
en fait cet indicateur là était essayé
d'avoir pour objectif qu'on soit plutôt
dans la fourchette haute de du de la
part des financements alloués à
l'intelligence artificielle en comparant
en tout cas ce qu'on avait lors
d'horizon 20 20 et ce qu'on a pour
horizon Europe et de suivre ça
mais c'est l'état du diagnostic pour
l'instant toute dernière question de
Catherine
question remarque j'ai pas l'impression
dont le plan horizon Vava appelé
boussole numérique qui explicitement
cité l'intelligence artificielle comme
une priorité j'ai vu le qu'il fallait
qu'on produise 20% de micro processeur
mais j'ai l'impression que la priorité
donnée à l'intelligence artificielle
c'est à posteriori qu'elle se déclenche
quand on constate que les États-Unis
vont investir massivement
dans ce secteur qui qu'on en mesure les
enjeux et qu'on voit que
l'investissement massif des États-Unis
risque de capter toutes nos entreprises
qui vont aller s'installer là-bas pour
travailler là-bas sur l'intelligence
artificielle donc est-ce que vous
confirmez que c'est plutôt à posteriori
que on se réveille et que on se met en
ordre de marche et j'ai l'impression que
c'est quand même ça ce qui ce qui se
passe et deuxième question adressée à
Monsieur vous avez donc évoqué les
échanges transatlantiques autour des
données donc la reconduction présumée
cette loi sur l'espionnage le FISA qui
parvient à échéance au 31 décembre de
cette année vous confirmez donc de
l'observation que vous faites dans vos
analyses que il n'y aura pas de progrès
de fait en matière de protection donc
est-ce qu'il serait négocié entre
l'Europe et les États-Unis en matière de
protection de garantie apportée aux
données des citoyens européens qui
seraient de fait transférer par le
mécanisme même de la loi FISA
si je peux répondre tenter de répondre
brièvement votre double question la
première c'est que sur les allocations
horizons Europe notre source là pour le
coup j'ai sous les yeux c'est la Cour
des comptes européennes qui commence à
travailler aussi sur le sujet donc il
faudra attendre d'import sur les 10
milliards que j'ai cités 2 milliards et
demi relèveraient du plan horizon Europe
pour l'intelligence artificielle alors
c'est peut-être expo que ça a été
reconstitué puisque nous n'avons pas
fait d'analyses Paname mais voilà 2
milliards et demi sur 2 milliards serait
dans le plan horizon Europe sur votre
dernière question madame je crains que
nous puissions pas répondre parce que
nous ne suivons pas les négociations non
pas travailler particulièrement sur ce
point on peut avoir des opinions
personnelles mais voilà donc je crois
que vous demandez aux responsables de
l'administration du gouvernement leur
réponse sur le succès ou pas de cette
négociation
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs pour cet éclairage très précis
et très utile à notre connaissance et
notre réflexion sur sur l'IA et puis
nous manquons pas de suivre la
continuité de vos travaux et de et de
vos analyses merci bonne journée votre
disposition à tous merci Monsieur
prudent